hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher two years ago I started writing
this book where is wonderful world of
maths it's a cheesy title for a cheesy
person and what this book is about is
that when I was at school
loving the humanities and never really
appreciating mathematics is a subject I
came from that background and then as I
began preparing to be a mathematics
teacher and then started teaching it I
discovered all of these things about
mathematics that I had never known in
high school and I thought these are
amazing and surprising and beautiful and
these really gripped me and I thought if
people knew more about this if people
heard these melodies of mathematics they
may be able to come to a richer and
deeper appreciation of this subject so
things like how in nature you know a
bolt of lightning and the shape of a
river delta and the branches of a tree
and the capillaries that transport blood
around your body they all shared the
same geometry what is up with that and
the answer is fractal geometry is one of
most amazing things that students don't
learn very much about at school and if
they can sort of grab onto that and
realize that there are answers to the
questions like this but mathematics is a
sense that allows us to perceive the
world in a whole new way then they'll be
able to enjoy and appreciate it and
that's that's what this book is about
every chapter is a new thing that I
discovered that I thought I can't
believe I don't know this and I bet
others don't know her too I wonder if
they'd be interested in discovering it
as well